MANDY WAITE: Welcome, everybody.
Hello.
How's it all going?
Good to see you all here.
Thanks for coming to
this talk, specifically.
There's many, many talks here
all going on at the same time.
So I'm really, really
pleased to see you here, so
thank you for coming.
And I hope you really
get a good chance
to enjoy all of Next,
particularly upstairs
on the third floor,
the showcase, which
we spent the last three
or four months building.
And we think it's a
lot of fun, so we'd
love to see you up there.
If you have any questions,
I'll be crawling around there,
generally.
And if you kind of get
stuck and need help,
if you see anybody wearing a
jacket like this with developer
relations on the back, you can
come up and ask us questions
and we will make sure that
you get them answered for you.
OK?
So welcome, thank
you for coming.
We're going to talk about design
and secure user experience
into your products.
And my name is Mandy Waite,
I am a developer advocate.
I work on Google Cloud--
Google Cloud Platform
specifically-- now we
have this more wider umbrella.
And you can find me on
Twitter at @tekgrrl, OK?
So please feel free to tweet
me if you have any questions
that we don't answer today.
So yeah, how many of
you are developers?
Wow.
That's awesome.
How many of you
and not developers?
OK, interesting.
That's the other half,
because some people
didn't put their hands
up, which is interesting.
OK.
We're just going to have more
of a developer focus, generally.
But we are going to talk
about some UX stuff upfront
before we get to the
more detailed things
that developers will care about.
The agenda is
something like this.
I don't normally do agendas,
so building good security
UX is where we start.
We're going to go through that.
Then we're going to look at
something called Google Safe
Browsing.
How many of you heard of
Google Safe Browsing before?
Excellent.
Most of you have used it.
Most of you have used
it without probably
knowing that you were using it.
We'll get into that shortly.
Security UX.
We are in a world where
security is vital.
We need to build security
into everything that we build.
It should never really
be an afterthought,
but it has for a long time been.
So we want to talk
about how this works
within the context of Google.
Not necessary in the context
of building new products
generally, but more to
all of the experience
that we've gained
over the years.
And also look at
the tools that we
provide that can
actually help you build
secure UX into your products.
OK so this is a bridge.
It's a good picture of a bridge.
It's got guardrails.
Gaurdrails protect
pedestrians from--
and probably cyclists as well--
from the traffic on one side
and the water on the other.
They do a very effective
job of that as well.
And as do these things as
well-- these interstitial--
these warnings that pop up that
people see on a regular basis.
These effectively protect people
from things that are ahead.
Things like phishing, or
malware, or unwanted software
generally.
These things are really
powerful and really useful,
but they are hard to design
and are very hard to get right.
So I'd like to talk
today about some of that
and how that works.
So warnings, ultimately, attempt
to convince users to stop
doing what they're doing.
OK?
You know how easy
that is, right?
To convince people to stop
doing what they're doing.
No, I will do this.
I will do this.
And it's a fine art.
It's a trade off.
It's checks and balances.
There's a lot of things
involved in getting this right,
and there's a lot of
research involved.
I'm hoping that we can
show you some of that.
So why would a user
ignore a warning
like the one we just saw
in the previous page?
Why we would ignore that?
Or more importantly the bigger
one, which is like this.
You see these, why
would you ignore it?
And there are generally
three main reasons
why people might ignore it--
there are more.
These are the ones we
think are important.
Today, in this talk, all of them
are important, and all of them
should be given
into consideration.
But the ones we really
want to mention today
are the fact that some
interstitial like that
will likely be interrupting
what a user is doing.
Something they want
to actually get done,
and it may well be that
they're under kind of pressure
to get it done as well.
So they want to move ahead.
They want to go to
and visit the site
that they visited regularly--
maybe not very long ago.
They want to download
the software because they
know that this software is
good, but these warnings
are coming up
telling them to stop.
That's one reason why
people might ignore it.
Also the situation may
be highly technical.
And again this plays into
what we do-- as people,
we develop products,
not necessarily
the situation itself.
Even highly technical situations
can be explained in a way
that people can understand.
We'll go into that in
more detail very shortly.
Sometimes the risk
just isn't clear.
It may be something you do
on a regular basis, right?
You go to this site
every day, and today it's
broken for some reason.
Today it's coming up
with this big red sign,
and you don't
think that's right.
I don't know what the risk
is, I don't really care.
I'm going to click on
this and go ahead anyway.
So there's some of the reasons
that people may ignore warnings
like that.
There are some additional
challenges as well
that come up.
We really-- by developing
these interstitial
and you yourself
in the products--
you don't want to stop people
doing the right thing-- doing
something that they
should be entitled to do.
But we also need to make
sure that we keep a very low
false positive rate as well.
We need to gain some
trust into the system.
If we just fail all of the time
and are unreliable in that,
or not a trusted advisor then
we lose people's mind share.
They're likely to have less
trust in us in the future
when we display these
kind of messages.
And ultimately, this slide is
here to show the dancing pig
because the dancing pig
is funny, and it's cute.
And at this time of
day you need something
like that to uplift you
because it's that kind of day.
We're just over the hump.
We've had lunch, and
we need dancing pigs.
And ultimately,
it's reasonably true
that given a choice between
dancing pigs and security,
users will pick dancing pigs.
Now again, that's not the
kind of undermines security
in any way.
Dancing pigs are
interesting, but sometimes
going to the dancing
pigs may be dangerous.
So let's not worry too much
about the dancing pigs.
I don't know if they are
dangerous, but they could be.
All right, so that was a
quote from Edward Felten--
professor of computer
science at Princeton.
I just moved to America by
the way, four months ago.
I've lived here for four months,
it's wonderful, I like it.
I live-- in San Francisco,
which is where we are today--
it's strange.
Comprehension.
So we talked about--
we've set the scene
for secure UX.
Some of the key components of
that-- the key considerations
are around comprehension.
So we're going to talk
about comprehension
first before we move
on to the next stage.
So what does comprehension mean?
Comprehension ultimately
means, the users
understand what is going on.
They see these warnings,
maybe other information
you provide as part of
your user interface that
is based around security.
And when people read
this information--
when they see these
interstitial--
that kind of thing,
pop-ups, they
understand exactly
what's going on.
This is key.
It is confusing, people won't
be able to understand it
and won't be able to make
it do the right thing.
We want them to
do the right thing
and we'll talk about
that shortly as well.
So comprehension is--
I'm kind of interested
in this first sentence
because I originally
wrote it, and I kind of
changed my mind on it.
But I wanted to leave
it there anyway.
The user should be able to
make an informed decision.
Now, ultimately really
with these things,
we don't want them
to make a decision.
We want them to do the thing
that we want them to do.
So this shouldn't
really be a decision,
but we want to make
the right choice.
We want them to
actually say, "They
want me to skip going
ahead to the website.
They don't want me to
download the software.
I'm going to do it."
But ultimately, it
does play into that
because you have to kind
of balance the odds.
You have to take all of
the information available
and make a decision.
Will I click on this,
"back to safety" button,
or will I find a way to
circumvent it somehow by,
maybe digging into
these menus, which
may give me an option to
go forward which is really
what I want to do.
So it's kind of interesting.
It's a real trade off and
a real balancing game.
Ultimately, what
it comes down to is
the user should be
able to understand
the exact source of the threat.
They should be
able to understand
exactly what's at risk.
They're about send their
password to somebody
they don't trust because
of some phishing scam.
They also need to understand the
likelihood of it being false--
a false positive
warning, which may well
undermine the whole system.
They're used to getting
false positives,
and ultimately that may
mean that they have very
little trust in the system.
So Microsoft have--
well, some time ago--
did a study and
they called it Neat.
And Neat is-- based on
these principles here--
we would like to simultaneously
accomplish these things--
all of them together.
And as you can
see some of them--
there's a bit of a tension
between some of them.
We want it to be presented
in a non-technical language.
We can't make any
assumptions about people's
technical background.
You people here may
well be a fully versed
with all of the kind of
technology that's out there.
And we can present you with
stack traces and such like,
and you'll say, ah, it's a
stack trace I like this one.
It was a Java stack trace
and it's about that long,
and I actually
can't find anything
meaningful in it, which is
always quite interesting.
We want to present it
in a non-technical way.
Reading level should
be fairly low.
We want to make sure that
everybody can read it.
And again, not everybody is
a native English speaker.
Not everybody is old,
or older, like we are--
or like I am at least.
We want things to be as
brief as possible, as well.
We don't want people
to have to read
from reams and reams and
reams of verbiage just
to find out what's going on.
We want to be very specific
about the risk as well.
And we want to provide
enough information.
And as you can see,
there's some tension there.
Be as brief as possible,
provide enough information.
You go to get that balance.
Number one would be being
very specific about the risk,
but not using any kind
of technical jargon--
that also makes it
more complicated.
There is some tensions here.
You do your best, and
you do some trade offs,
and we'll talk yet about
some of that more shortly.
How are you all doing?
You all good?
One question, was it warm
in the keynote today?
Some people say-- oh, no?
Oh, interesting.
I was fighting fires
out in the showcase,
so I didn't get to see it,
but I will watch it later.
What we don't aim to do.
We are not trying to
accomplish providing
some kind of complete
description of the issue.
That would probably
go back to what we
looked on the previous slide.
Some of the things we want
to accomplish simultaneously.
One thing is we don't want
to do is actually provide
a complete description
of the issue.
Will not provide any information
for software engineers.
Again, we can do.
and often at Google,
we see things
that other people don't see.
Slight traces and such
like when things go wrong,
which is quite interesting
and useful for us engineers.
And sometimes it probably is
a bit frustrating for software
engineers to see these kind of
interstitials and you'd say,
hmm, I want to know more
about what happened.
We can do that.
We can handle that.
We can provide-- learn more
links or advance drop downs
that people can use to
actually find out more about
what's going on--
drill deeper into the problem.
And there's also things
like developer tools
and suchlike that
can actually help you
understand better what went on.
So you could be using
Chrome web tools
and such like to find
exactly what happened
underneath the hood.
This is where we end up.
We end up with these kind
of lovely red interstitial,
and the bright color
is a very strong one.
Maybe one day I
can ask Alison why
we choose to have this kind
of very strong red color.
But it does provide
that kind of warning.
Do not go ahead,
this is dangerous.
It's hard to ignore.
So we're going to talk
more about these shortly.
But these come from a
product called Safe Browsing,
and we are going to talk in
detail about that very shortly.
And the next thing is
beyond comprehension.
We need to think
about adherence.
This again is making sure people
do the right thing, which is
the thing we want them to do.
So adherence is--
users do what you want.
That's important.
We're not putting these
things up for a laugh.
We're putting them up
because it is serious.
We've detected some
kind of threat ahead.
and we'll look at competence
levels and suchlike shortly,
but we really wanting them to
do the thing we tell them to do.
So we can measure that.
Let's talk about
exactly how we can
make it more likely
that people will
do the thing that you want.
So opinionated design is the
first tenant around that.
We need the design
to be reasonably
opinionated about what we
want you to do as a user.
So we've had great success when
the user interface provides
things like, very
clear instructions.
It provides an attractive
preferred choice.
Again, the way we present
it may play into this.
It provides an
unattractive other choice,
or it provides no
other choice at all.
Being very strongly
opinionated we may say,
this file is infected
with a virus.
We are not going to
let you download it.
And that's an extremely
opinionated view of the world.
And often you don't
go that far, but you
may be prepared to
if you are very, very
confident that the
threat is there and real.
The very act of downloading an
infected file into your system
can automatically
infect your system.
Let's be thorough about that.
So looking at this one,
this is the current download
interstitial aught to pop-pop
the way you've seen nowadays.
If you try to download a file
that's infected with something
and we've detected
that it's infected,
we will tell you to discard it.
We said the file is dangerous,
so Chrome has blocked it.
And when you click on the down
arrow you find out, learn more.
You don't say, eh, ignore
my warning and go ahead.
You say, learn more and we
can tell you more about it,
but we really do not
want you to download it.
You think about why
we're doing this.
We want to reduce
infection rates.
We want to reduce infected
sites across the globe.
We want to make the internet
a safer place for everybody.
And this is where tools such
as Safe Browsing playing in.
So here's an example.
And I'm going to dive into
some older content note
that's been around for a while.
So some of these screens
is going to be fairly old,
but I think it's
still interesting
because they show some of
the ways we've progressed
over the way we see these kind
of security user experience.
And you probably all at
some point in your life--
unless you're extremely
young-- seen this one, which is
the HTTPS warning from Chrome.
So Chrome 2014-ish would
of display this certificate
if this certificate--
this message--
if SSL wasn't working correctly.
If it seemed that you were
trying to go to a site
that didn't have a
valid certificate.
And we're not very
opinionated here.
We say, proceed
anyway, back to safety.
So who thinks this
is opinionated?
Who thinks this is
not opinionated?
OK, right.
It's not really opinionated.
We offer two choices.
The first one is,
proceed anyway.
The other one is back to safety.
Now there is some background
around HTTPS warnings
that you should probably know--
we're going to get too shortly.
But really we're not
being very opinionated.
We should really want
them to go back to safety.
They may have more
information about what's
going on than we
do, but we do really
want them to go back to safety.
But we've offered them this
option to proceed anyway.
We have a help me
understand link which
may actually clarify the issue.
What you are looking
at today, at what
we had today within Chrome.
And this is the
HTTPS warning today.
Your connection is not private.
Attackers might be trying to
steal your information from,
whatever.
They may be trying to get your
passwords, and your messages,
and your credit cards.
This is important stuff.
You don't want to give
this stuff away to people.
I'm your kind of person who
actually tears labels off
of boxes and envelopes and
shreds them or compresses them
and throws them
away-- such a way
that no body can ever
read them, so nobody
can get any kind of
information from me.
You do not want to
share your password,
and your social security
number in the clear.
So we'd really want
you to not do this.
You may have additional
information, as I say,
that may lead you to want
to go ahead and do it.
So we have a big blue
"back to safety" button.
So now, we don't want it to
be a red button, obviously
because red is not
going to be help here.
So a nice blue one, a
nice color that people
can actually respond to.
If the need to find out
more they can go to advance.
And if they need to, they
have other information
that we're not aware of
they can choose to proceed.
So that's opinionated,
very opinionated.
So a couple more
examples, and these
are older interstitial,
or pop-ups
that we've had in the past.
The first one is
somewhat more or less
opinionated than the first one.
Both are a little bit
borderline opinionated.
If you can see the first
one, important point
here-- adherence
can be measured.
You have control.
You can understand what users
do when they see these pop-ups.
What do they do?
What step did they take?
Did they choose
to keep the file?
Did they choose to
discard the file?
We can measure that, and
that's what's called adherence.
How many people decided to
actually heed your warning.
So in this case with the
first one, 72% of people
decided, yeah, OK, fair cop.
I'm British, by the way,
so I say colloquialisms
like fair cop, mate.
72% people actually decided
to discard in the first case,
which isn't very high.
It's not bad, but it's
not where we want to be.
We want to be at a
100% if possible.
The bottom one is better.
We're saying the
file is malicious.
We have a strong opinion
that it's malicious.
We're not saying it
appears malicious.
We're saying, hey, this
thing is malicious.
Don't download it.
But we still offer
a couple of options.
And 93% adherence rate here.
So people did the right thing.
People did the thing that
we wanted them to do,
and much more frequently than
they did with the first case.
Oh, sorry about that.
Something's changed.
I'm sure somebody is editing
my slides when I'm talking
or I've just made last
minute changes that
didn't come right--
OK.
Good.
We will ignore this slide.
This slide is a mistake,
but we will get back to it
very shortly.
Warning fatigue.
As you can imagine--
and you've probably
experienced this yourself--
if you ever used Windows
7 back in the early days
when it first launched and
you had to approve everything.
You had so many pop-ups
it was unbelievable,
or maybe that was
Windows 8, I'm not sure.
But warning fatigue--
how many times have you
had warning fatigue where
the warning keeps popping up.
It seems like the same one.
You're not quite sure
if it is the same one,
but it does seem to be
annoying and irritating,
and doesn't seem to be
particularly relevant.
There is evidence
of warning fatigue,
but you have to be careful.
And we have to think
about this and we'll
try to get to the
bottom of that shortly.
So this is again,
HTTPS warnings.
We're looking at adherents
from different countries,
and I'll leave that
to you to guess
which countries they are because
I don't know all of them.
I do not know what
TR is, for example,
and I should have checked.
Number of prior
warning impressions.
So basically, the first time
you see this warning pop up,
around about 75% to 77%
of people on average
would do the thing that
you wanted them to do.
But after a while-- after
five of these within a period
of time--
people get kind of fatigued
by the whole process,
and that they're
much less likely,
or significantly less
likely-- in this case around
get's dropped down around 50%--
are likely to follow
your instructions,
or follow your advice, and
that's not a great situation.
But this isn't just
about warning fatigue.
It's also about many,
many different vectors,
particularly around what
type of threat it is
and how you present it.
So all these things
need consideration,
which is why we're going to talk
about measurement very shortly.
And just to kind of contrast,
unwanted software warnings.
This is different.
This is different behavior.
So, UWS, unwanted software.
So this is the
same kind of thing.
Adherence is high to begin with.
People generally don't
want unwanted software.
These things are just annoying.
You didn't ask for it.
It's not like it's blocking you
from doing something you really
want to do.
It's just like a pop-up
saying, download this.
OK, I'm not going
to download that.
I don't know what it is.
You're probably going to say,
ignore, get rid of, delete,
whatever.
But at the same time--
the first time you're going
to see it is around 95%.
But as you get more
and more of them,
you're even more likely, not
significantly, but even more
likely to follow the
instructions to discard it,
so that's significant.
We need to understand
the difference
between showing HTTPS warnings
and showing unwanted software
warnings.
So this all comes
back to measurement,
which we'll talk about shortly.
So false alarms, and
repeats warnings as well.
This is quite
interesting, slow kittens.
I'm sorry, I pulled
this one out earlier.
We have to mention
kittens in Google Talk,
it's a rule of the company.
So each false alarm
reduces the credibility
of a warning system.
This is a fairly old quote from
a white paper, slow kittens.
And just to talk
about that, we found
that people don't respond
favorably to repeat warnings.
And now we're talking about
repeat of the same thing.
It's clearly the same thing
being repeated over and over
again.
If you do something, if you
click or make a decision
to do something based on
one of these interstitial
we should remember it
for some period of time.
But what's the ideal
period of time?
Should it be a day,
should it be a week,
or actually be an hour before
we display that message again?
If you get an SSL warning and
decide to continue shouldn't we
just remember that forever?
We'll always let you
go there, or should we
constantly remind you?
Should be constantly remind
you every five minutes?
Because we remind you
every day or every week?
And there's this whole
thing about regrets as well.
Some people regret
that decision.
They decide to move
forward to go to a site
that they don't trust, or to
download some malware that they
shouldn't download, and maybe
they regret that decision.
And you have these things
called the adherence rate, which
we already talked about and
also the regret rate as well.
That's harder to measure and
I don't know a huge amount
about it, [INAUDIBLE] started
reading this in white paper.
But if you are
interested in that,
come and talk to me afterwards.
But there is a sweet spot
here over about a week--
if we remember your decision
as a user for about a week,
and then represent that
again a week later then that
seems to be about
the right sweet spot
in terms of getting
the adherence right.
And in terms of making
sure that people
don't regret their decision.
So let's talk about measurement.
Well, I kind of mentioned
measurement quite a lot so far.
And I'm not going to
go into huge details,
I want to get into Safe
Browsing and talk about that.
How many of you came here
to talk about Safe Browsing
specifically?
OK, no.
Good.
So we're going to hopefully
introduce you to that
and enlighten you.
Measurement.
Measurement is important.
And here's some measurements.
And again, these go
back awhile but they're
from a really good document--
a good presentation
that's been presented
before back in 2014.
Chrome's malware interstitial
use to look like this.
And it's again,
strongly opinionated.
Here it has a go back option,
has an advanced option.
Our confidence in this-- to
the fact that there is malware
behind whatever
you're trying to do--
is extremely strong.
And upwards of-- my
clock just reset--
the confidence is
extremely strong.
So we're really confident
that what you're trying to do
is download malware.
We're telling you that
it's malware, and people--
25% of them nearly--
are still choosing
to proceed and actually
download malware.
That's a little bit scary.
We need to do better.
We should always be aiming
to get 100% adherence.
This is effectively
77% adherence.
If we look at these--
and again comparing
to-- we're going
to compare Chrome and Firefox.
We see the old nonfatal
SSL warning in Chrome,
proceed anyway or
back to safety.
We have less
confidence about this.
I think it's a little
bit more than that.
I think the graphic
people who have actually
adjusted it a little bit,
but it's not that high.
It's reasonable but
it's not that high.
There are many
different reasons why
an SSL certificate
may be invalid,
and it may not be a threat.
It may be the SSL
[INAUDIBLE] certificate
for example, which means
it doesn't tie back
into a route certificate.
So there are many reasons why
there may be problems with SSL
that we would flag as being
something problematic.
So we have less confidence here.
And we found the click through
rate will be around 68%.
68% of people decided to
proceed to the site anyway.
Now, what is it?
Is it the nature of the
warning that's the problem,
or is it the way it's presented?
Well, let's take
a look at Firefox.
At Firefox, at exactly the same
time had this interstitial.
This connection is untrusted,
get me out of here.
We've all seen this as well
if you've used Firefox before.
"Get me out of here."
It's fairly clear,
is very opinionated.
We have the same level
of confidence though.
This is still SSL,
there's nothing different
when you're using
Firefox and Chrome,
but you can see the
click through rate
is now down to 33%.
So this is important.
This is an important
measurement.
We have to improve on that.
If you see a 68% click
through, and you're pretty sure
you don't want them to
continue you need to fix that.
But only by measuring it
can you actually understand
how to fix it, what
to do, what you
need to change in
the way you message
this, the way you
present it to the user.
The only way you can fix
that is by measuring it.
Measurement is
ultimately the key
to how effective comprehension
and adherence are.
You do your AB
testing, you maybe
have different versions
the interstitial,
and we've done that
many, many times.
Alison, are we doing that
kind of AB testing currently
with Safe Browsing?
Yep.
So we do this kind of AB
testing all of the time.
And we can get the
statistics on what people do,
and we can work out
and fine tune it
until we get it exactly right.
Click through rates,
adherence, effectively
can vary based on a number
of different factors
as we saw from the
Firefox, Chrome comparison.
And there's always
room for improvement.
So do more and more
measurement is always
going to get you better results.
And you may often
see bad things,
worse things happen when you go
a certain path, which case you
can course correct.
But you should never be doing
these things in isolation.
Roll them out two at
a time, do AB testing.
So that's the first part.
So we talked about
secure UX generally.
Let's talk about Google and
the whole context of Google.
We have a lot of experience
observing traffic.
We do it a lot, as
you can imagine.
And we do it in a lot
of different ways,
a lot of different
types of traffic.
So we have a lot
of experience when
it comes to actually building
secure UX into our products.
And again, that's still ongoing.
It's always going to be
an ongoing effort based
on the feedback that we get
from people's interactions
with our products.
And what we want to do is
also talk about something
that can actually aid you
in building more secure user
experience into your products
by using this particular product
called Google Safe Browsing.
This is a bit of a play
on Google's vision, which
is ultimately-- make the world's
information safely accessible.
Really doing a lot
of work upfront
to make it easier to
access information.
Not only easier, sorry,
but also safer as well.
So making it easier has
been part of the mission.
Making it safely accessible
is the other part of it.
And we're going to talk
about this in more detail.
Again, these lovely red signs--
interstitial-- these
come from Safe Browsing.
So as I say, you all
probably used Safe Browsing
before because
you've all probably
seen warnings like this before.
You've clicked on
the link, maybe
it was through some phishing
email-- hopefully not.
Or maybe it was just a link
that turned up some where.
You clicked on it,
hopefully these things
don't turn up in search results.
We can get rid of those,
but at some point in time
you will see these
kind of interstitial.
The left one is the
Chrome interstitial,
the other one is
Chrome and Android.
Oh, interesting.
My speaker notes are here.
It's amazing.
[LAUGHS] I didn't
expect to see that.
So how does Google
Safe Browsing work?
So basically we do crawl--
as you know, as you
can imagine-- we
crawl many, many pages.
Lots and lots of
pages every day.
Tens of millions sites
effectively looking
for harmful content.
And we also have
the notion of, we
can get leads from
other sources as well--
how they can also
play into this.
And what the result is,
we will build blacklist
from reputation
databases that can
be used as the back end for
this safe browsing API that
is built into, or built
into Chromes functionality
and also into Firefox--
and into other products as well.
Safe Browsing, surprisingly
or maybe unsurprisingly--
if you've seen it a few
times-- is it effectively
protecting one billion
people globally.
And while about 1.1 was the
last measurement we had.
It's probably higher now.
And ultimately
every day we crawl
over 10 million URLS,
Chrome extensions,
executable, android
applications every day.
So we have good information
about what's infected
and what's not.
We have various
algorithms that can
be used to detect that
kind of scams going forward
and also infected software.
We've detected around
about 50,000 harmful sites
every week.
And Safe Browsing
for Google is built
into most of our products.
So if we look at Google Play,
if you install an application,
or upload an applications
into the Google Play Store,
Safe Browsing will
come into play.
It will be looking for
malicious content being
uploaded to the Play Store.
And also through Verify
Apps, it will also
be used to protect when
you install from sources
other than Google Play as well.
It's built into Google Search,
so if there is infected
malware out there, even if we do
return the search page for it--
if we don't know it's infected
we would display that.
Most of the time we will
filter that out there.
Google Ads.
Google Ads is
extremely important
because when you see an
ad, and you click on it,
it takes you to a link.
We don't want to take
you to a page that
may be a phishing scam or
providing malicious content.
So this is built
into Ads as well.
It's built into Gmail,
in terms of Gmail,
it protects users by
identifying things
as links in email messages.
And it shows warnings
if you just on them.
Also it protects the Chrome Web
Store from potentially harmful
extensions.
So this is Google Safe Browsing
built into our products.
But we also have
Safe Browsing support
for many of the browsers
that are out there as well.
So it protects things
like Google Chrome,
it protects Firefox, Safari,
and also Chrome on Android.
Ultimately-- I kind of
ruined the next slide--
it protects around about
two billion devices.
So that's a really
ridiculous high number.
Two billion devices are
protected by Safe Browsing
through things like Chrome,
Firefox, and Chrome on Android.
So we also show around
about 50 million warnings
to users on a weekly basis.
So those red
interstitial you see
appear around about over
50 million times a week.
We also provide support
for Webmasters and also
for developers.
So we build in Safe Browsing
into Safety Net within Android,
and that lets mobile developers
check URLS against the Safe
Browsing lists.
It's in fact the
actual same API that's
used by Chrome on Android.
And thousands of developers
and network administrators
use the Safe Browsing
API to protect
their platform and their users.
If you can imagine that tens
and thousands of sites get
hacked every day to serve
harmful content ultimately.
Safe Browsing
ultimately notifies
Webmasters of site owners that
their sites have been infected.
So we have this
notification process,
which you can sign up for.
We have a link at the
end that will show you
how to get to that.
But basically, if
you're a Webmaster
and you're signed up for
Google Webmaster's, you
can get access to all
of these notifications.
And they will tell
you if your sites
are hosting malicious content.
But ultimately, we have great
power, but with that reach
comes great responsibility.
And our challenge is to provide
the best protection for you
while being very precise
with our results.
So as you can imagine,
Google Safe Browsing
is likely to be a target.
The people who are creating
these malicious content--
these malicious
sites-- are going
to want to try to find a way
around our detection systems
effectively.
And there are various
different ways
of doing that, which
we look at now.
Bare with me.
So here we see-- oh, the
lines are not very clear,
at least on my screen--
so here we have something
on the internet,
some content being served.
Maybe this is a site, maybe
it's some piece of content
that's being served.
And when Google Safe
Browsing comes to look at it,
it sees that's OK,
there's no problems there.
But when-- say we call
her Jane over there--
she goes to download
the same content.
She sees something
completely different.
She sees malicious software.
This could be a problem,
and there's various ways
that attackers can
actually hide themselves
from Google's detection.
One of the most
common is IP cloaking.
Effectively, serving
benign content
to our detection systems, but
doing something very different
when somebody else
on the internet
comes to actually
access that content.
And cyber criminals generally
don't spend too much time
on the individual
vulnerabilities.
They tend to move on to
different exploits very,
very quickly.
So you have to really
be ahead of the game.
There's also thing called
Malvertising, malware
being delivered through ads.
It's a whole notion
of cloaking, it
extends beyond just
the IP addresses.
And our best protection,
where possible,
is to appear exactly
like the end user traffic
wherever we can.
If we look like end
user traffic then
our detection systems
will not be flagged,
as being a detection system.
We will see the content
that ordinary users will.
So that's something
that's constantly
ongoing within Safe Browsing.
One story from the trenches.
So I had to originally
[INAUDIBLE] a little bit more
complicated to explain, so I'm
going to stick with this one.
So you imagine you're
downloading software.
You're using the
browser, potentially
to download software.
The download is complete.
We have to decide whether
we should flag the content
as malicious or not.
The browser will do
certain things upfront.
It can have some level of trust.
It's a safe file type.
This safe file type
is one that's not
likely to infect the system.
And so we can say, that's
fine, we will download that.
We will provide it to the user,
they will be able to access it.
If it's a potentially
harmful file, [INAUDIBLE]
then we need to go to
the next level which is,
does it come from a
trusted source or not?
And if it comes from a
trusted source, that's fine.
Great.
OK, we know that
source, we can trust it,
we can download the file
and provide it to the user.
It it's an untrusted
source, we're
still not completely
confident with them
there's going to
be a problem here.
At that point we want to
pull in Safe Browsing--
send the content
to Safe Browsing,
and have it decide for us
as to whether the content is
malicious.
At that point we can make a
decision on whether it's safe,
or whether it's harmful.
In this case, a
trusted source is
important to note to be either
local, somewhere on your file
system, or it could be a
whiteless domain, or a trusted
sign up.
So that's important here because
what you could potentially do--
got my clicker-- what you
could potentially do here
is break that chain.
If you can get the
download completed,
but then you can invoke
some JavaScript code,
you can actually make the
file appear on the file system
and then sort it back to
the user via JavaScript.
So the browser actually believes
that the file was sourced
from a local file system--
one of these trusted
sources-- and that way
can now bypass the system
because it's a trusted
source and it would end here.
So that's a real problem.
And that's the kind
of detection issues
that we have to deal with.
And harmful JavaScript
can cause potential issues
when it comes to bypassing
Safe Browsing security.
So let's talk about
partnerships as well.
Safe Browsing data is
very hard and takes
some tremendous
amounts of resources,
most of the challenges
are scale and evasion.
But we want to make sure our
work can have the biggest
impact as possible.
For that we need to
work with other people,
with third parties-- with
you people-- on integration.
So we can't do it alone.
And I mentioned
earlier that we have
sources that can provide
more input into the list
that we build.
So we collaborate with
partners both inside
and outside of Google.
And we also partner
with external companies
to combat harmful content
and protect users.
There are free
main tools that you
can use to protect your users.
So the first one is we protect
network and content owners.
So we can-- by using
the Safe Browsing
for network and
content owners program,
you can actually
have us send you
notifications when we
detect harmful content
on your network-- if it's
hosted on your network.
And currently we
have around about--
and this is a little
bit of an old number,
it may be higher now--
roughly around about 22,000
ASNs autonomous system numbers
subscribed.
That's around about
40% of active ASNs
out there currently.
So the ASNs effectively
uniquely identifies
each network on the internet.
So we can help there.
We can help you understand--
on your own networks--
whether you have any kind of
malicious content being hosted.
And therefore help you to
avoid propagating it out
to the rest of the
world, or internally
within your own company.
Also when it comes to
Webmasters-- again,
we've mentioned this already--
with Google Webmaster's
you can sign up by the Security
Council for notifications.
We can check your sites
for malicious content.
It's very, very simple.
Very easy to get started with.
You just had to verify
that you own the property,
and then we can provide
information like this.
And we're doing
this because we want
to minimize the
impact on all users
out there on the internet.
So we can help you.
Actually I understand that there
are issues on your own size.
This is actually extremely
powerful as well.
So that sends out around about
750,000 notifications per year.
And it reduces the
duration of size
being infected by around about
60%, which is really important.
So this kind of reduces
the need for Safe Browsing
to actually display
interstitial like we've
seen before because we're
reducing the infection rates.
And also 80%
successful clean up.
So these sites are
infected, many of them
get cleaned up
very, very quickly.
Without those notifications
they would not
have been aware that they
were infected until maybe they
had some other kind of report
that they were infected,
so Webmaster's really
helps with that.
We also-- for
developers-- we have APIs,
and APIs that you can
build into your own code.
And so this where we're going
to get a little bit deeper
into the technical
aspects of this.
So the first one
is the Lookup API.
The Lookup API is used basically
to detect malicious content,
detect content stored
URLs, and give you
a report back as to what
the threat was seeing.
It's very simple to use, but
there are some downsides.
One downside is we
learn about your URLs.
You might not want to
share those URLs with us.
Limited Lookup volume, you
can't do that many Lookups
but it's kind of
limited around that.
And it's also a little
bit higher latency.
So around about 150
milliseconds latency on average.
That would play into
user experience too.
If you had to check
every URL, you
would have 150
milliseconds latency
like we're in the
Safe Browsing API.
There's also the Android
Lookup API as well.
And again, this is ideal
for mobile applications.
We have a link for this at
the end, how to get started.
It provides significant
bandwidth savings, in the fact
that you don't have to actually
go all the way to Google
to do it.
It preserves privacy
because you do not
need to send URLs to
Google to be able to make
the detections successful.
And it's used by
Android Chrome today.
The other thing is a combination
of the Lookup API, which
we talked about earlier--
and there's something called
the Update API.
This scale is extremely
well and we're
going to show you a
demo just shortly.
It preserves privacy.
Again, we do not need
to send URLs to Google.
It's used by the major browsers
including Firefox, and Chrome.
It does require client code,
but mostly developers so that's
great, because you
like writing code.
There are some links here on
how to get started for all three
of those.
The first one is the Safe
Browsing before look up
API documentation.
On
developer.android.com/training
We have an index page
on Safe Browsing.
And also for the update API we
had the similar documentation.
And these links are at
the end of the slide
and you will get
access to the slides.
So don't worry about
taking notes of them now.
And if you do want to
know in the meantime,
you can always tweet me
and I can send it to you.
So let's go into a quick demo.
How long are we doing?
16 minutes, OK.
Can we switch to demo?
Oh, I was going to sleep.
[LAUGHS] I'm an anime fan, I
make no apologies for that.
What we're going to do here
we're going to access the API.
We have the Safe Browsing API.
Anybody can access it if you
have a Google Cloud Platform
project, you will need
an API key for this.
And to make things easier
so I don't show the API key,
I'll set it into a variable.
So I'll be using the
API key as a variable,
I'm not actually
display my API key.
So that it doesn't
show up in the video.
What we can do is
the usual stuff.
We can use a kill command
to send a message to an API.
And we're going to use this one.
I will walk through it.
I'm hoping you can all
see that very clearly.
Maybe it does need
to be bigger, even.
Hopefully you can all see that.
So basically we're just
using the kill command,
we're setting the header,
we set in the content
touch will be application JSON.
We're providing a body and using
the minus, minus data flag.
This is provided for
a file in this case.
That's the at symbol,
SBmalware.jason and I'm
going to send it to the API.
We're providing
this one parameters
to the argument
to the [INAUDIBLE]
matches find API endpoint.
The API key, which
is said specified
in an environment variable.
So that's fairly
straightforward.
We can just hit
that, and we will
get back very, very
quickly a message saying
we detected some malware.
That's really easy, right?
Very easy to do.
You can use standard
REST libraries
to build that kind of query.
And you can send multiple URLs
at any given time to the API
and a single API call up to 500.
So let's have a quick look
at what that file was,
and what we actually
sent to the API.
Let's be malware--
load this up--
Oh, come on.
So we provide a meta data that
is specific to your company,
it doesn't identify
you, but it does help
you look into your audit logs.
So effectively, the meta data
client ID, and client version,
I entered some information
about what we want to look up.
We're providing free
fret entries here.
One is going to--
well, all three
of them are going
to something called
testsafebrowsing.appspot.com
Which is an App Engine
application that
simulates threats.
One thing we really
don't want to do
is kind of use real life
threats in a demo, that's
not a good thing to do, but even
when it's going to be on video.
So we have this set up and
it's really, really powerful
and really, really useful.
If you go to touch browsing,
testsafebrowsing@appspot.com
on it's own you'll see
some interesting stuff.
Let's have a quick look at it.
If I could find
my browser window.
It seems have gone away.
And to make that bigger.
So you can go here, and you can
use this for testing generally.
You don't want to kind of
send lots and lots of traffic
to this.
It's not designed
for that, but you
can test your algorithms,
your code, and [INAUDIBLE].
So we can actually send
a phishing warning,
a malware warning, a unwanted
software warning link.
These were the three things
we talked about earlier.
We can just simply
click on this link
and it will see the big
red sign in real life.
That's something we can use to
test for the testing is what
we're using in the demo today.
So back to here.
So we've specified free
threat entries here.
They are all URLs.
We also talk about
what the difference
is between a URL and the other
options we can use shortly.
We're also saying we're
looking for malware.
We're also specifying
a platform,
we're looking for
Windows specifically.
And we're specifying that
the threat entry types
are going to provide all URLs.
That's what we need to do,
to be able to do a query.
So, we provided that file, we
passed into the call command,
or we provide one of these
information is adjacent object
and we send it to the
API via a REST call
via some kind of library.
That's really straightforward.
And if we go back to here, we
can do this for others as well.
So we have one set up
for phishing as well--
maybe not.
I can't spell the word phishing.
I've spent the last
five days trying
to spell the word
phishing, and I keep
messing up that second page.
It's time we're looking for
threat type social engineering
on a Linux platform,
and the URL that we've
found phishing
attacks on, is the one
we saw earlier on the
test browsing side.
Quick mention of
castrations as well.
We would like you very
much to understand
that you can't keep making the
same call over and over again.
And any kind of API is often
under danger from tight loops,
people going, is this a threat?
Is this a threat?
What we do is provide
back a castration period.
We want you to cast results
of this for five minutes.
I'm asking again about
that URL for five minutes.
So be provide information
in your response,
it'll help you understand
how long you should cache it
for before you go and
check on that URL again.
OK?
It's unlikely to change
in those five minutes.
You're going to go back
and visit at some point,
but in the meantime
you should cache it.
The last one is the
unwanted software.
We will just look at that
one very, very quickly.
And that's very similar.
This time we have a threat type
detected of unwanted software.
And it's platform
type is any platform,
and URL is again, the
Safe Browsing application.
The rest of the data is
pretty much the same.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
But we looked at what
we sent you earlier,
and that was
actually three URLs.
So two of those it didn't detect
issues with because we only
specifically looking for--
in this case, malware.
So we don't only pick
up on the malware issue.
We could actually extend
that to look for all three
if we wanted to.
And I apologize for my typing
which is absolutely terrible.
I should probably be wearing
glasses while typing, it's
very hard to see the screen.
So now we've done that.
We can save that.
And we can send the malware
and went back again.
Go back up in the history.
And now we get
three results back.
We can see the all three of
the URLs reported issues,
as expected.
But before when we
were sending them,
we're only looking for specific
attacks and specific threats,
you can specify all of the
threats if you want to.
And the same for
platform type as well,
you can specify
multiple platform types.
The other part is what was
the Update API, which we're
going to talk about
in the slides firstly,
but I'll show it
now to save time.
And we provide a go
client library for this.
It's effectively a reference
implementation of a library
that you can use.
So you can build on this,
you can use as an example,
you can actually write your own
code in a different language.
But on GitHub we provide
a go client library
that you can use, and that's
what I'm going to use now.
So the first thing to do is to--
I'm just going to clear my
screen first, bare with me.
So we're going to install--
what is known as SB Server--
if you go to Safe Browsing
github.com/google/safebrowsing
you'll find all of the code
there.
So I'm going to hit return now.
And that's already installed.
So we didn't actually
install [INAUDIBLE] up,
installing it in patches
in this demo all day.
What we can do now is use--
or run the SB server command.
An SB server command
will run a local proxy
to the Safe Browsing API for us.
And I'm going to use my history
to make it easier so I don't
have to type all of this in.
We're going to run it from
the go path bin directory
where the built
file was installed.
We're going to specify the API
key again as we did before.
And we've all seem to
specify parts with database,
in this case /temp /sb.db.
I wouldn't recommend using
/temp to store as data,
but for the purpose of this demo
it means I don't have to worry
about sticking it somewhere that
I may have to [INAUDIBLE] for.
And also being to specify
my server address,
so port 8080 on local host.
And so we run this now.
It will look at the database.
Initially it looks at the
database and said it's stale
and now it's
healthy What's going
on here underneath the hood?
We specify the database.
We didn't do that before.
We had to look up.
If actually what
we're doing here
is pulling down
those lists, those
blacklists we had
before, reputation lists,
and pulling them down locally
and caching them locally.
So now what we can do
is we can make look up
calls against a local database.
Now the thing is about this
is that we are not storing
the URLs in the database.
We are storing
hashes of the URLs.
So effectively,
what we do is we go
for a process of
canonicalizing the URLs,
then hashing URLs
and then taking
the first four
bytes of that hash
and using that as a lookup.
So when we do lookups
locally, we're
actually doing them in
much different ways.
What we would do, we would
send in URLs to the API.
Now when we send a URL to
the API itself directly,
it's still doing the
same thing for us.
The databases are stored on
the Safe Browsing all hashes.
And what we do is when
we receive the URL is
we can convert it into a hash.
And then we compare that
to the stored lists.
And effectively, what we do
for the lookup, for the update
API is pull that
list down locally,
so we can make calls
against it locally.
We never have to send
those URLs to Google.
We never have to make
additional calls to Google
to get the results back.
We have lower latency as well.
I'm not going to go into
that since I'm running out
of time, so I'm going to
quickly get back to my slides
and wrap up.
Apologize for that,
do talk a lot.
Can we go back to the
slides, thank you.
Oh, wonderful.
We went through some of this.
We saw most of these.
Threat types, malware, social
engineering, unwanted software,
unspecified threat types.
Others as well, different
platforms that we support,
also hash URL and digest
are threat entries.
Now URL was obvious,
we saw that.
We sent a URL to the
Safe Browsing API.
But we could also
specify a hash as well.
If we know what the hash is,
we can send that directly
to the API, or to the
update version of the API.
And we can do the same
for digest as well.
So we can actually bypass any
URL to anything effectively.
So ultimately,
Safe Browsing list
contain hashes effectively,
or at least hash prefixes.
The first four
bytes of the hash.
This dramatically
reduces bandwidth,
and makes life easier for us.
This is a combination of the
update and the lookup API.
Once we have SB server that
we saw earlier running,
when we make calls against that,
we are effectively making calls
to a version of a local version
of the lookup API, which is why
it says update plus lookup API.
So not it looks like
something like this.
We have the hash prefix
database stored locally.
The database
version is sent back
to the Safe Browsing
and any additions,
or removals are sent
back to the Safe Browsing
local version of the database.
And you saw that when we
went through the demo.
And you saw that the
database was stale,
and then the
database was healthy.
And then it was
pulling down updates
to make sure it had the
latest versions of them.
So this is the whole
process by which
those hashes are arrived at.
We have this
canonicalization process,
which you see on the left here.
And also with that
it's converted
to these four byte hashes which
is stored in the reputation
databases.
That's local.
Whenever we want
to do a lookup, we
will send back the prefix
back to Safe Browsing
and we will get back a
list of results to match.
And here's an example of
actual code written in Go.
This is similar
to the code that's
actually on the GitHub repo,
the one we showed earlier.
So you can write your
code very easily and go.
But again, if you want to
use other languages, using
a RESTful API, or
RESTful library
will work perfectly for you.
So just an example
using the SB server
that we looked at before,
the SB server acts as a proxy
actually for the API.
It exposes a version locally
of the JSON lookup API.
We can send requests
to that proxy
and it will get
hashed lookups back
from Safe Browsing
as needed, otherwise
it will use its local database.
And this is what the
JSON lookup looks like.
We saw this earlier
in the demo code.
And here is a final kind of
version of what we actually
typed in earlier.
So when you get
the slides, you'll
know how to get
started with this.
I think this is also in
the GitHub readme file.
And just to quickly wrap up.
Apologies for the
small text again.
They modify these things
after you've make your slides
and used a smaller
font for some reason.
Comprehension and adherence
are the cornerstones
of very good security UX.
And what we've also talked about
today was Google Safe Browsing.
To get started, there
are three links here.
The best thing to do is actually
to search for Google Safe
Browsing in Google
search, and you'll
get access to these links.
Again, these will be in the
slides that are published.
So you can go to
safebrowsing@dev
elopers.google.com The
Webmaster's stuff is
all in there as
well, and also you
can sign up for the NetOps thing
through this URL right here.
It's not the greatest
user experience currently,
but it will
ultimately get better.